the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so this is a nano tool
macro principle process two five seven
zero and for undergraduate students and
257 for graduate student and it's
offered every two years so I'm glad to
say this is a probably largest audience
I've ever had and so that's a very
pleased to see the growing popularity
the last time we did a OpenCourseWare I
think there was a 2004 and that one we
had a voice recording and typewritten
notes and you can still go to the MIT
OpenCourseWare if you miss a lecture I
think although we do have changes the
changes are not dramatic so you can go
there and try to make that up if you
miss any lectures and this semester MIT
has a new initiative trying to put a
course or video online and that's why I
volunteered and also that way people can
read my book better it's a hard book to
read and in addition to my book there
are also a list of books they recommend
it because the USC that this course
really cover a wide range of topics so
we have given list of references for
each subject you can always go to other
books this is not necessary the use is
to understand but to say we put it in on
reserve in the library and with that I
think it's pretty much the housekeeping
item done and what I'm going to do next
is to give you some slide this I'm not
going to choose slides every week but
I'm going to give you some slides to to
see what's the scope of this course and
some motivation or side so any questions
if you look at the title this is nano -
macro transport process so we'll
emphasize the Nano
were emphasizing transport we're also
emphasizing the transition from Nano to
macro and so those are they this is a
slide from a colleague of mine before
say and here what we're showing the lens
skills that's in nature and learn skills
all for what we made artificially I say
leisure of course we have the biological
side you can say going to from molecules
through DNA to bacterial cells and
progressively increase in this scale and
then if we look at what people are
making from for example this
nanoparticles sometimes we call the
quantum dots as small as a few one two
to five nanometers and the two nano
wires and nano electronics where they
this is actually quite a few year old
I think the gate length in
semiconductors now is just around few
tens ten twenty nanometers so those are
they are making smaller and smaller
devices and of course at the end
whatever interfacing is at the macro
scale so when we go through small scales
the questions because you have learned a
lot in the transport theory for example
the question is are they valid or not
right and what if they are not valid
what are the alternatives and also we're
not just looking at the individual
nanoparticles when you put them together
and it will macro scale what's the
picture here so this is where this
course is trying to wrestle with and
that's in fact that most of my research
is looking to thinking how we can look
at this small and then how using the
small to do the big things particularly
most of the work I'm working on is the
heat transfer relate to
energy and energy is an odd skill so how
I can take small to go to the large and
let me give you two examples that from
research to show that when you go to
nano scale the classical theory that you
have learned breaks down and the first
example is a heat conduction example
right we we we know in heat conduction
we have four law and we have a thermal
conductivity of the materials and this
is the why example of nano this is in
fact transmission electron microscopy
image of a layer structure one layer the
bright layer is silicon the darker layer
is germanium so each layer is about two
nanometers and when you measure thermal
conductivity so you can take a silicon
because the one layer stick on the other
is germanium right so you have started
heat transfer it's parallel plates and
you can do thermal resistors to see
what's the factor with thermal
conductivity and you can say if I take a
silicon germanium thermal conductivity I
will predict that's the equivalent
thermal kinetic those open circles but
the experimentally measured dots are
order magnitude smaller and in fact we
have to go to complete different theory
in this case we have to go to boards my
equation to predict now so this is a
work that we started in 90s and now
we're doing quantum calculations on
those structures right so there's
significant departure from the classical
theory when you go to nano skills and is
another example you learn in thermal
radiation blackbody is the maximum on
thermal radiation right but see when we
go to nano scale when we put two objects
smaller the distance this was an MIT
webpage I really like this they're very
creative much less say this is a better
than what we did so that's a
slow blackbody radiation and that's
usually consider maximum and when we put
two surfaces down to nano scale right
here is 1 micron 100 nanometer and
attend nanometer we can go beyond the
Planck's law by several automatic do
right when I say we're this is a three
order magnitude we're not at the four
order magnitude and we're look we're
looking at what happens between that one
nanometer and contact and you see why
you Cure's right the factor is when I
put many materials together they say
it's a really particle when I do Canal
oh it's really the interface dominates
and so that interface is sometimes the
contact share each other sometimes they
do not so this is a the the connection I
say how I can take this nanoscale and
you actually go to macro scale so I this
is a propaganda I do nano I say once I
was asked by graduate students
summarized research in three words
that's like what I came up
nano heat energy and what I had
benefited over the years is I mean
mechanical engineer I'm a mechanical
engineer I always say at the end what I
do want to be useful right so I think
about atoms but I also think about
continue and I see we have few things we
can probably claim that that we had
really done some change in the materials
I gave an example on this thermal
connectivity [ __ ] germanium super
lattice the layer structure and we're
taking that to make a better thermal
actually energy converters because we
need amateurs with the pool heat
conduction and that we still need the
electron goes through so this is a very
contradictory requirement and currently
we're working on on this photon side
that were designing nano structured
to do user nest material to do solar
cells and we have a some of the most
conductive liquid just by putting
nanoparticles in the liquid and find out
what's the thermal conductivity in fact
at the end that we say I don't want the
average in nano that's where you
understand if you understand physics
another area is nano also right so we
work on people put in a particular into
liquid some say have high thermal
conductivity others go to lab they say
no we can't measure it we struggle for
four years and we should we figure out
we say okay
usually what we need is a macro in one
direction and Natalie in the other
direction and that's how we achieve the
best thermal conductivity and we also
have most conductive polymers I get a
call every every every month almost
affirming industry to say can we have it
so the question was polymers plastics
are typically pool heat conduction right
so people always want to make them more
conductive some most people work is
making them more electrically conductive
but see when I ask the question I've got
a call from Intel say can you think
about how I can better manage your heat
I start thinking of plastics so how I
make them more conductive and if you
look at how people are usually do it
they're putting composite they're
putting a lot of component and make them
averaged speaking a higher conduct
higher heat conduction and when I think
about this okay of course that's
approach one of the approach but see the
question we ask is a molecule a polymer
really a poor heat conductor it's a
molecular champuli hikmah poor heat
conductor if you think of a polyethylene
which is sixty percent of the plastics
and it's a carbon carbon bonding right
and carbon carbon what's the highest the
thermal conductivity mature anyone know
diamond carbon-carbon bond right so that
suggests and the molecular chain the
Russian I should have a high heat
thermal conductivity right so you think
about the nano you single more let
molecules and in fact I say of course I
can put in most fancy or theory I go to
Fermi and he did work in the fifties he
said one dimensional conductor has the
infinite thermal conductivity so they
give me a lot of motivation to look into
that and in turn we did succeed in
actually create the most conductive
polymer except I seen one single fiber
nano fiber right so I say I got a course
every month from company I said you guys
have to wait or you give me money we do
more research because I need to scale
this up right because you usually am not
using single nano fiber to put in your
heat exchangers so that's what I say you
need to think of nano you have leather
you can generate more new ideas but also
you to think to how you can go to macro
and so this when I say what's the matter
for energy right if you think about
energy at the end it's molecules that
you will for mechanical engineer
familiar with it's the electrons and
it's a fold hung delight or its lattice
vibration fold on but those are the
basic energy carrier there some other
terms say but let's see those are the
basic energy carriers right Woodstock
high risk Allen's the mean free path and
the wavelengths right so the mean free
path of air molecule will get into that
very shown in this room is about a
hundred nanometer and that means they
travel 100 nanometer and the collided
with another molecule and the
wavelengths of light visible light
how much wavelength
400 nanometer to 5 a 2 to 700 nanometer
ring right
so 1/2 micron and so a lot of this in
the nanometer range and if you think
about energy fundamentally if you can
control the energy level of material has
for example if I make a quantum dots
that I showed before 5 nanometer spheres
right
particles what happens is a electron
quantum mechanics it's a way right and
that way we had the wavelength and
typical wavelength is you can say let's
say 10 nanometer now a wave of 10
nanometer you try to fit into that 5
nanometer quantum dot what happens you
squeeze that wave right you squeeze that
way the energy level will change so if
you look at the professor mu nipple in
this homepage you will see the quantum
dots of different colors that's because
the energy level changed when you make
the size change so that's the one way
you can control the energy if you
control the energy now come to
mechanical engineering or any
engineering what do you do you control
the thermodynamics right energy is the
most fundamental so you can control
Surma dynamics another is say transport
right if you look at the where the loss
is up if you see ok second law Carlos a
you can get to color efficiency pretty
good if we you can get all color
efficiency you should all be pleased
right
but say we lose about 60% of useful
energy if you look at the energy input
output and Carlos say you can get the
landing portion right so we're were see
you can improve the transport if you can
control the energy carrier
traveling there interaction there
traveling right so I said the air
molecule is about 100 nanometers they
mean free path and that seems so awfully
small but if you open your computer you
look at the hard disk the separation
between the disk itself which is routing
about 10,000 rpm and the magnetic head
is a few nanometers few nanometers in
everybody's computer so you go through
this describe company and that they have
give up the Newton because the day it's
basically how to allow to crash that
this hat with the disk right it's a
fluid mechanics problem and they have
given up a solving the navier-stokes
equation because a full mechanic so
that's so nervous Stokes equation they
don't use it in there for long time ago
they give them up and one day they call
me they say we have one nanometer
problem so what nano me right at the
time I didn't know you in this
separation so why you care about it
because at the time they're about 20
nanometer separation and they say that's
already 5 5 percent uncertainty right
and now they are going beyond they
they're only say there are below 10
nanometers we still didn't figure out
what was that one nanometer problem so
but their ladder will see so basically
using the boundaries and you at this
regime you need to go to different laws
so what whether we are talking in this
course and in this book are really this
is my view of trying to have a picture
from nano to they continue and firstly
you need to understand the basic energy
states the energy levels in the material
so that really need need the quantum
mechanics solid state and then I do heat
transfers I need to bring in the
temperature
that's a statistics sir more energy and
then we need to look at how those energy
carrier moves so that's the transport
and transport that you have continuum
laws you have also the you need to go
the long continuum you need to vary
whether you need to see in the quantum
regime where you have to look at the
wave nature or you can forget about it
right so the what I would like you to
have is to develop that picture say if
you have a problem and people come to
you and say well in this regime I'm very
the weather I can still use my the
continuum right if you feel comfortable
to tell them yeah there's no problem
just to go you you may get a ten percent
error twenty percent error but say at
least say I want to devote the comfort
level of when you can use uh say what
kind of transport pictures and in fact I
say if you look at the book it's a
parallel treatment say all four
electrons molecules photons photons
right so the that's that's the way I
aren't I understand the object the the
subjects and I was it I've been always a
mechanical engineer I first learned
summer radiation photons and of course I
learned all those continuum theory and
it turns out that if you understand that
one carrier you can make a rudder it's
easy relatively easy analogy for other
carriers and at least in this is
so-called the dilute gas picture they
are all bt behavior a very similar so
this is what I'm most familiar with
and wave Maxwell equation and by say
this is a where most engineers familiar
with right Ohm's law for alone
you'll ensure stress and what those are
the continuum right let's see if I go to
photon radiation where if you think
about the full time from the Sun to
earth
you don't go to solve diffusion equation
for that now in fact I say this a place
is just a street trajectory ballistic
right so this will happens if I have a
describe I have a disc the example here
average speaking the molecule travel 100
nanometer and now the molecule if there
is a molecule in the gap they'll collide
the wall they don't collide with each
other right that's a ballistic transfer
picture so what I want to have is
developing say when I need to think
about the way we need to think about
they forget by the way by say still need
to see what's the boundary effects and
they eventually say they continue
so it's a very the challenge for this is
most of you I know most my students they
are mechanical engineers right with the
mechanical engineering background and
that's where we're most familiar with
most comfortably and what do we add to
this is a lot of a new subject and the
typically taken many years to build up
but it took myself many years to build
up so I'm very ambitious let's say I
want to teach you when semester you will
be inundated with the terminology okay
and also by say D at what I'm hoping is
at the end you gain something you gain
that say you can look and say I have a
sense of from nano from molecules to the
continued so that's a water we have in
the in the general introduction any
questions I want you feel free to ask
questions
before I turn off the computer because I
I'll do that say every week I actually
were spend at the end of lecture ten
minutes also to have some relaxation
time relaxing time and what I wanted to
to show you is I don't know how many of
you go to journals and then most of you
are graduate students and you should go
to journal every week if not every day
and just look at what other people are
doing so ah when you a new graduate
student you don't go to joiner often and
you go to journal you look at that this
is most of this stuff you don't
understand other than the ones that if
you heat work on heat transfer you go
journal heat transfer maybe you know
what the people are talking right so ah
what might say if I want to start with
the any journal not medical not bad
matter go I'm nothing now is there any
other journal you tell me and I want to
say okay where you are this today and
where you are at the end of the semester
and my ambition is for you to see look
at the paper title and 50% you say maybe
I can take a look maybe as I am NOT
completely ignorant so give me a name of
a journal
ah later ok let's look at take a look
right
so the Wow for the challenge of later is
that now most of them are actually on
biological but but that's fine let's say
still see what today what's the news
this week yeah social level one social
network I want to think about the
entropy of social network all right I
see I I tell you at the end I only need
you if you if you your career at the end
you say ok there are only three words
you need to understand not just nano
heat energy right there are only three
words you need to understand energy
momentum and entropy okay if you feel
comfortable with that
let's look hi Betsy
we're at the technical papers dear
research book hello that those are those
are the sign this way I want to go more
into the plasma right what is the plasma
and so when I look at this right quantum
current the company of mechanical
oscillator to off recovery mode I look
at that paper I haven't read it right
clearly I'm what I was thinking anybody
will guess what they will be talking
about
so you will say I I don't know okay so
my guess is were probably related to
force momentum of photon right it's a
mechanical and so it turns out that the
photon has a momentum and then carry
force once anything has a moment then we
can generate force so after your cavity
so you will learn this stuff okay so the
quantum control I'm not very familiar
but say what I can say is the object
cavity the modes and also the coherency
issue we'll talk not exactly related to
photon but related transport right see
how I can go from that normally the wave
a coherent state to eventually I can
forget about the coherence of the waves
and treating my the particles so the my
point is to say at the end of what I'm
hoping is that you open journal like
apply physics and nano letters or
science a leisure
you're not scared okay a lot of
terminologies that the you probably
didn't know and they'll stick to you and
threw to you and then maybe you remember
something okay so let's start talking
more details so what I want to start
with is for you to think about what are
the laws you have learned to see what
are they okay I wanted get thee
so we talked about briefly you just
follow my syllabus we show the slides on
motivations and scope now let's go to
classical laws not necessary classical I
just want to say what have a loss that
you think you have learned and
particular I like to transport right ok
let's start with the conservation so
I'll use this side right we have
conservation what are the conservation
laws ah
you have mass conservation momentum with
ardor energy first law other charge so
charge on what charge transport what a
conservation of charge okay yeah that's
huh parity I'm not familiar with that
okay yeah I heard the lane what others
know we're not going to touch much on
conservation laws Einstein say that
anything can be broken except the first
and second law so I'm not going to touch
much on okay well say okay even though
it's not a conservation by the second
law is say you can write the entropy
generation you can still write the
equation there right so those are the
things we don't touch much there are
discussions in literature say you can
break the second law that's and mean the
time very short time scale and the
statistical speaking you could have
deviations that's possible and let's
look at transport tell me more on the
transport laws you learn so let's say
you learn some of you familiar with the
heat something from of you may be
familiar with charge or fluids or mass
right tell me they will all see in those
disciplines ah
okay so let's do heat right right heat
in the in terms of the laws the Fourier
law is for heat conduction
so conduction right I this course I put
a prerequisite either to double five
level and 2005 from other department is
basically heat conduction heat transfer
thermal fluids course and in your
department there is also of course nano
engineering if you take in that this
will be easier because there lot of
there's some overlap but see if not you
can still survive so heat conduction we
have the simplest picture when one side
is the hot the other side is a call and
there's a heat flow inside right and the
law of governing the heat conduction I
write this simplest form is the Fourier
law right Fourier law of heat conduction
the heat flux equals thermal
conductivity times temperature gradient
and this is a one dimension that I'm
reading and this is a heat flux the unit
here is a watt meter square and the
thermal conductivity is a mature
property at the macro scale we go to
Llano you'll find this is no longer
material property because it's structure
dependent but the unit of that is a watt
per meter per Kelvin and we just said
diamond is most conductive heat
conducting material and in fact some
people will say is the carbon nanotube
graphene so I thought this is a nano
scale on one side they can go very high
and the other side I give example
can go very low right so this is one of
the knows transport laws and this is a
this is a conservation law and for this
flow what do we call constitutive
relation it's a relation between
temperature and the heat flux right in
those consider relation many of them
have their regime of validity and then
you can it slow you can break them okay
and so since we're doing heat what are
the other heat loss
okay let's say conversion right so for
conversion of course for those who now
live in Stokes equation and you'll be to
this very complicated differential
equations but in this simplest picture
when we do convection is I have heated a
surface let's say this is the wall and I
have a fluids and away from the wall the
fluid temperature is ta ambient and then
I write the law for cooling is the Q
equals h TW minus ta right this is the
Luden's law of cooling right Newton's
law of cooling
and H here is the heat transfer
coefficient the unit of H is different
from K if you look at what we had for
fuller law and this is what meter square
per Kelvin H is not a material property
it depends on how fast is fluid will
Flutie use right and the geometry so
it's so for that you need to go to
newest ox equation to solve if the case
is simple if it's case is complicated
you go to do the experiment right and
one thing I want to say remain you if
you do fluids problem or heat transfer
conversion on the war you often invoke a
condition what is that condition now
asleep right so the molecule the
velocity of molecule is zero or equal to
the velocity of the war and temperature
you were a temperature of the wall
that's the no slip boundary condition
and area of you learn fluids or heat
transfer notes there but I say that's
not valid that's not true in fact there
is always sleep there's always velocity
and temperature sorry it's just a
normally it's too small so you can
ignore it and you will see why
downstream okay so conduction convection
radiation let's look at radiation
what's the radiation law
okay so let's write both
stefan-boltzmann or QE course for
blackbody Sigma T fourth power right and
the stefan-boltzmann constant the five
point six seven ten to the minus eight
watt meter square and in this case
because it's not near with temperature
so you have to use Kelvin Kelvin fourth
power and I already commented before we
can go if we go now we can go way beyond
this okay so those are the our heat
transfer laws I'm more ambitious I want
to hear more if your electrical engineer
you tell me or Templar engineer what are
they transport laws or fluids right
these are the ones that I'm familiar
with
okay brief diffusion
let me simplify it further let's just
write Ohm's law well would the right
drift diffusion okay so ah here I have a
heat and I will have a charge and so
Ohm's law I really want to write a
differential form so the differential
form for almost law is a current density
so here is a flux the write flux is the
heat flux is a watt per meter square and
here current density is and per meter
square okay eCourse
electric conductivity times the electric
field they write okay
so the here I have an meter square and
here I have Oh immersion in worse ohm
per meter it doesn't look like a
differential form so I'm going to write
it into a differential form the electric
field is the derivative of potential
right so I have Sigma and D Phi DX and I
have a shoe that mountain sign right so
Phi is a electrostatic potential okay so
that's for charge right more we talked
about the heat we talked about charge
fluid guy tell me
ah momentum okay Newton sure stress not
related force to the momentum right so
Newton shear stress no shear stress and
this is a again if I take a simplest
picture if I have X I have Y and in the
fluids there's a there's shear stress
tau XY right and in the simplest form
tau XY equals mu deal dy were you this
is the velocity yo this is a velocity
way right so here we have dynamic
viscosity the shear stress is a Newton
meter square and the dynamic squid with
God is the Newton second meter square
okay so we have during shear stress no
and you can write into more complex
tensor form 3d I'm always writing the
same place what what else
mess tell me mass transport fix laws
right fix roll so mass we have how here
that we have so we have mass diffusion
and the mass flux equals Rho T and D say
DX right the mass flux here you say is a
kilogram per meter square flux is always
a lot at a meter square and the
diffusivity 10 or is density diffusivity
is a meter square per second and this
say is the mass fraction you can go to
check a unit right so we wrote all this
constitutive equation and in the first
homework you would derive so even though
say most of the classes that you'll
probably give it but you can use the
simplest picture by counting the numbers
and if you have a gradient of velocity
you have gradient of temperature your
gradient see in the you know you're
actually a field you will see that this
can be when you go to see the granular
picture the those nodes can be easily
derived and I'll show you in the lecture
and let's make sure how to derive it
okay so we said those are the continuum
those are the ones at least you feel
comfortable and the question we ask is
when we go to nano the other still valid
right if they are not valid what
alternatives we have and to do
that we need to go to granular picture
we need to look at the individual chart
individual molecules and individual
photons so what we are going to look at
next let's let's look at take a look at
the simplest microscopic picture for
this transport okay so let's first look
either we talked about heat that's why
I'm most familiar with right so let's
first talk about the heat and let's say
heat conduction so we draw this picture
on one side
is hot the other side is cold we see
there is a heat flow and now I want to
look at the granular let's say I have a
box of with molecules let's see the
right one side that is the hot the other
side is cold let's say we have gas
molecules inside how heat is actually
conducted right I'm sorry
guess molecule so I take the simplest
guess there's no vibration
I take Heaney
right so this side is hotter right and
the gas molecule they do random motion
and at least say when I say random
motion about half of them would go this
way and they were collided with the
whole a higher temperature and what
again is it again a higher kinetic
energy because this is a higher
temperature when they bounce back they
have a higher kinetic energy faster
right so we begin energy when the
collision and they bounce back the lexer
molecule they say will have slightly
lower energy so is the two ball
collision problem and during that
process they'll pass some of the energy
to the Lexx molecule and the next
molecule against have different chance
going this way and that way and it's
that diffusion process that he goes from
hot to the cold right so it's the random
walk and diffusion process and in fact
turns out other than radiation orders
are similar process okay and the if this
is not an easy picture in the history of
heat because we a long time ago people
have this heat is there something
calorie right code when you have to
object touching each other the cholera
flow from one side to the other so when
you go to supermarket is do you have the
calories it's a wrong concept we use the
terminology today
now this is a gas molecule what about
metal what care is hitting metal so
electrons right so I put the metal and
what's the transport picture one side is
hot the other side is cold so that's the
picture
it's the electron now is the gas in the
solid they're bound by the ions but they
actually can know quite a few distance
beyond their nitrogen see electron that
these are free electrons the electron
actually can move around and again they
will have a collision distance right we
say the air molecule collision distance
is 100 nanometer and the electron
collision distance can be few nanometer
to you and longer 100 nanometer or you
micron depends on temperature so it's
easily amazing they're minutes minutes
of atom if you think of one micron how
many items there and the electron can
zip through them and no collision so of
course at the end there is a collision
so if you think about that case is the
electron power few distance and the
collide and that's the same process so
it's the electron gas when you can give
a name like a gas right so it's the
electron gas
okay and next what about a loam or
nonmetal
diamond ah it's a full-on okay but most
of you probably the first time I heard
phonon in fact mother first time I heard
full none but I remember when I was a
graduate student walking into a electric
engineer and they have an open house
they had an open house to their lab show
I said work on heat transfer and the guy
said oh you work on photons and the most
mechanical engineer when they work heat
transfer they don't know what it was
used for right in some not of you
probably just to graduate from
undergraduate degree in mechanical
engineering how many of you have heard
the phone long heat transfer course
right molarity okay so what is the
fullness
I had a once I had a say I was teaching
another university and I had a colleague
and he said in my scars and I end he
said I still don't know what is a phone
what do you know what is the full huh
yes I hope huh vibration it is a
vibration yes yeah it's another electron
so let's say what is the unknown metal
dielectric let's first concrete right so
what holds the mature together is the
force right and if I think about two
atoms in a material and the potential
between the two atom that's a typical
curve is like this this is the
separation between the two and this is
the potential energy
this is the minimum point that's
normally their separation distance right
when the further away the attract each
other and when they are too close they
repulse each other because there is
charging the every atom has a positive
charge and negative charge at the end is
the charge that's the glue for the force
for the potential of anima - okay and so
that's the force that's the minimum
distance and I'll Kurt the potential and
the force is the force is the gradient
of potential you okay right and at this
minimum point that first should order
graded is zero so the I can write they
in fact I can write the potentially this
for shoulder if I do the expansion and I
will write the force roughly the
potential expansion first order zero the
second order give me a linear term
that's a sprint so the two atoms the
petunias your this simply is
approximation is the spring holding them
together okay so when I have a crystal
like a diamond
it's a periodic arrangement of atoms so
they have their equilibrium position and
they are holding together by this
Springs right
so this spring now you have you have
this let work you look at it it has
vibration and the vibration has a
different frequency right so when we
have vibration frequency frequency nu
and this is where it has to go to
quantum mechanics and it turns out that
the vibrational energy cannot be
arbitrary and the energy has to be
multiple of n H nu
the H is the Planck constant 6.6 10
today I only remember if you are a
physicist enough at me this is a H times
SiC jar 10 second because the physicist
use a Tomica unit it didn't carry this
large negative numbers but I only
remember the SI unit so I carried a
large number smaller Planck constant H
is Punkins so what what this says is the
basic energy is H nu that's Hong Kong
that's a that's the fundamental unit of
the vibrational energy and that
fundamental unit is called a fuller it's
another like a electron has a mass but
say it's a very similar to photon photon
don't have a mess
it's turns out the photon has a
frequency and the fundamental unit that
you get again is the H nu 4 photon and
in fact I say eat later and you learned
a plunk relation is the energy is always
related to frequencies through H nu ok
so the photon is the quantized a
vibrational energy in the material a
photon is a one want i canta of that
vibration so if you do that
and going through this is where you will
have to wait probably until chapter 5
that it will go from the vibrational
modes is a wave right we say I
originally I treat them as a particles
and that as a full-on gas so I go from
that wave picture mode to a gas picture
in the solid so for the heat conduction
it's the full-on gas in the solid and
once I think about the gas is the same
picture right when one side is hot that
photon gets a lock at the wall the gain
higher energy to go two legs
so the full-on mean free paths again the
collision between the photons and turns
out that it's a wide range and we're
doing quantum calculations on this and
some of them says one nanometer order so
is what micron
okay so for heat conduction that basic
picture is this gas picture and so
that's why I'm treating photon electron
and photon and at the end is a photon
gas and they just say the photon from
the Sun when we treated the photon gas
but they don't obey the diffusion noise
like a full Yolo they go ballistic
there's no scatter I'm sure they reach
the earth okay so that's they are
conduction convection what's the
difference right microscopically sure
for convection
right we say okay you have high or and
the ambient we gave the Newton law of
cooling right so what's the microscopic
picture of conversion what's the
difference from conduction yeah very
good answer so what in heat conduction
is molecules are moving randomly and
they're moving at a 300 meter per second
pretty fast but their average velocity
vector is zero right so for the
conduction we have the average velocity
is zero but for convection this is not
zero okay and that is could be one meter
per second two meter per second but we I
said that molecules are always doing
random motions 300 meter per second much
faster right but the you know convection
is the more effective that's because
they are not a diffusion because when
they move from one place to another
place they carry all that energy
directly from one place to other right
that energy is enthalpy so that's the
fundamental difference you still got
this random motion so when you go
through back to thing about
navier-stocks equation you still have
heat conduction term there I ran the
motions there but you got a convective
term okay so that's a convection and in
fact if you take that and convection is
almost the same as conduction except the
rather than you just have a Dirac and
moving term so I would say it's
fundamental is not
two new a picture at this skill and then
we think about radiation right what's
the thermal radiation
what's the radiation from a radio with a
difference huh so the radiation from the
heat source is the photon the radiation
electromagnetic wave from radio source
we normally don't call the photon it's
also photon it is all full time and all
photon in free space you learn this at
high school speed of night witness
frequency right we channel do turn
what's the frequency I turn to nineteen
point five well I forgot that's
megahertz or kilohertz doe but it
doesn't matter is a megahertz or killers
I think huh huh anybody remember
I can so let me just put the Henry
kilohertz
I know there are 200 kilohertz range and
so what's the wavelengths speed outline
three ten to the eighth meters per
second right so that gives me
wavelengths 10 to the fifth
ten days a kilometer okay so it's a
photon and the energy is H nu - that's a
low energy photon and it's generated by
you know that station right oscillating
current generate this electromagnetic
wave
it's an oscillating current so it's
artificially you oscillate what's the
thermal radiation huh
the it's a vibration of all frequency
that's the what is that it's okay it is
the color of white radio frequency but
there's still oscillating current don't
think say all radiation is a thermal
motion right is this similar generated
oscillating current and think about the
atoms think about electrons one electron
move around the general corner right so
it's the cermony random motion generated
and this is a much smaller oscillator
much faster so if you think about
wavelength is the 0.5 micron it's the
point five ten to the minus six this is
a ten to the fourteen then right
frequencies within two fourteen is an
hour longer Henry Kitteridge
okay so that's what a difference but
let's say in terms of propagation of
thermal radiation it's actually the same
Maxwell equation it's not different from
what the electrical engineer does is it
this source that's different
once they are out the propagation you
write the same equation okay so at the
end there are not many equations and so
that's the heat transfer we can go
either we can pick up another object
subject to here let's say charge Ohm's
law right I want show you easily how I
can derive Ohm's law and let's look
either the charge
and of course I do a lot of hand waving
and I have a conductor electrons I have
a protein sure right what's the force on
the electron anybody remember if I have
a charge I have protein sure if I my
potential is the e let's say this is the
X X the ration right the force F X
equals charge times the field right so
it's a minus of e times e^x this is what
I really heat
the money sign I often get confused okay
so I have force and I'm going to write
this so Newton's second law F equals MA
so this is M D V X DT right F equals MA
and it turns out that what the electron
does we mentioned before you collide
right it can go certain distance then
collide so the acceleration time is
between the collision and collide a
accelerated collide actually so I'm
going to give a hand waving if I do that
integration I say that's how that's the
average time between the collision so my
velocity then is if I integrate this
right
I gather e epsilon X divided by M times
tau this is the drift velocity the
electron at the end is sort of under
this field is the moving average
velocity of the charge okay
and now if I have this velocity
I can write the current write the
current what's card current is just the
charge per unit time going across
certain area so if I look at the current
right because the VX is the average of
velocity so if I know the charge density
per unit volume then I write my J equals
take the current write is JX is the
charge that's in Coulomb pants N and
Hansa a VX that's my current density
right if you look at the unit e anyone
in remember again 1.6 10 to the minus 19
coulomb okay one charge again I'm
awkward I remember SI unit and here is
one over meters cubic because that's a
charge density per unit volume and then
you do Lea this is a meter per second
and you get the here is a Coulomb per
meter square per second Coulomb per
meter square is the amp per meter square
right that's your card in honey so if I
plug in there what I have the e square
and tau M times n times epsilon X that's
almost all right this is my electric
conductivity this is Sigma you've seen X
okay
let's do another exam so Howie that have
charged a now to think about force
noticing about the momentum right the
pressure let's say we have heat charge
momentum okay
what's the pressure when you have a box
of gas you have pressure what is that
pressure so this is the gas
I have box of gas inside
I have Monaco's right they're moving the
movement randomly and the pressure is
when the gas here the war right and they
were change the Russian bounce back
there's a momentum change the momentum
change give you the force so I can argue
with you inside I don't know what's the
pressure now you stick up an emitter
there you will measure that momentum
change and you measure the pressure
right okay so here is the of course the
force let's say is f x on the wall is a
single molecule is the reacts to this
larger than the romance MV x less than
zero divided by delta T so that's the
single molecule acting on the wall of
force right now I want to find the
pressure in the chamber I have a lot of
molecules again the density molecular
density n and they are coming towards
their wall and bounce back so let me
just make my simplest perfecting war so
the coming velocity across the bouncing
back velocity so it's a factor of two
and I have a lot of molecules here this
is molecular density is n 2 random so
half of them coming towards the wall
so my is 1/2 and and in terms of the
rate the time comes to steal VX that's
the rate that's the really coming and
this give me the delta T eyelid and then
say I have a 2 MV x I'm assuming like I
said this way X is just reflecting back
so this will give me pressure again you
go to check a unit ok so what I get I
get this pressure equals n M way x
squared right we x squared is the
velocity component in X Direction
squared so it's just 1/3 ruff speaking
right homogenized
so is this 1/3 of Y squared ok so what I
have here is n m 1 third way square ok
now I want to show you ideal gas flow
and V Square and this is you have to go
you have to wait a little bit but then
let me give you say the equipartition
that's a statistical thermo says here
equals MV square because it has three we
x revise it with a so each of this mode
will give you this board my constant
times T so this one you wait statistic
your thermo fundamental result equal
partition ok so I plug in this would I
have that 1 through 10 so that's 3
when half kinds of my square is K T KB T
so what I have here is then is a n KB T
and this is ideal gas no still doesn't
look like ideal gas all right one more
step and one more step I'll stop here
okay so n is the number of molecules per
unit volume so I put a plug I multiply a
volume so I have P way equal number of
molecules
Tambor is my constant times T doesn't
look like a are yet so I to n divided by
n a Avogadro constant and a KBT and this
is your R that's your universal gas
constant and this is your mole fraction
mole fraction times you are universal
gas constant times T PV equals NRT right
I do guys know I'm leaving I'm not doing
rigorously of course okay so uh anyway I
remember knows KB with some number
boards mine consulate
1.38 ten to the minus 23
jar per Kelvin okay so you go to look at
Avogadro's constant right honey is a six
point six about 16 to 23 to cancel six
times one point three eight give you
right that's the universal gas comes
okay so basically what we're we're going
is to look at those microscopic picture
and look at the electrons look at the
photons look at molecule photons and
come to this n counting how many we have
come to how much energy they have and
count how long they travel and with that
you can do all the counting so the host
a thread line for the transport is the
county in the basically see the
microscopic carriers and for that we
need to go another more detail okay so
any questions I will stop here oh yeah I
send out a questionnaire I would like
you to feel it and hand back to me so
that I can have some idea what's your
background what's the interest okay
you